all right we are
live for another reading and
uh this will be some portions
of uh reason fulfilled by revelation
1930s christian philosophy debates in
france looks like we've already got nine
people
here so i'm going to talk just a little
bit about what we'll do it's been
a little bit of a time since we had one
of these readings
and then i'm going to jump right into
the text itself
so i've been doing some readings of
portions of this work reason fulfilled
by revelation
which is a 2011
text mostly comprised of
um translations from key documents
of the christian philosophy debates that
took place in
french-speaking venues not not everybody
involved was
was actually french but um
took place between about 1931 to 1935
1936 and we're still in the
long historical introduction that i
wrote
to it before we get to the actual meet
today we're going to go over the two
sections philosophy in a christian state
jacques mariten and then catholic
philosophy
maurice blondell so about
15 pages or so of the text and then
i will take questions address comments
um anything like that that we want to
have in the
the the chat so no further ado let me
get started
um philosophy in a christian state
jacques mariten
two main features mark maraten's
involvements in the debates
a continuity of progressive development
of his position
and critical engagement of opposed
positions
his 1933 essay on christian philosophy
represents a culmination of studies
beginning with maritime's contribution
to the 1931
society frances de philosophy session
which he
reworked and expanded into the 1932 de
la nocionde de philosophica
and then incorporated into the essay he
later re-examined the
issue of christian philosophy in his
1935 book science
and wisdom since his essay in science
and wisdom have long been available in
translation and studied in depth
here i restrict myself to several main
themes
of two earlier documents from the start
marathon aligns his position closely
with jill sones but works it out and
presents it through a much more
explicitly thomas thomas framework and
vocabulary
he signals his agreement this is a quote
on what is essential in this debate
and accepts the way in which jill so
envisages the problem
and indicates its solution and then he
adds that by
bringing the problem back onto the plane
of history
i think that he did not mean to suppress
the theoretical question but on the
contrary to leave it
open accordingly mara 10 intentionally
focuses on providing
such a theoretical account later
explaining that
while zhilson deliberately sets himself
in the historical point of view
i would like to bring together the
elements of a solution of a doctrinal
order
this solution centers on what he calls
the classical distinction between the
order of specification
and the order of exercise or as maritime
reformulates it the distinction between
the nature of philosophy of what
philosophy is
in itself and the state in which it is
found factually historically in the
human subject
and which pertains to its conditions of
existence and exercise
in the concrete although philosophy's
essence or nature must be considered by
means of abstraction since it nowhere
exists
in concrete actuality it possesses
definite features that thomas aquinas
determined construing
philosophical wisdom as the perfected
work of reason perfectum opus raziones
and affirming the essential naturality
or rationality of philosophy in
tomis philosophy considered in what
constitutes it formally as philosophy no
argument
proceeding from faith penetrates into
its texture
it derives intrinsically from reason and
rational critique alone
it retains its soundness and as
philosophy only from experiential or
intellectual evidence
and from demonstration in its nature
philosophy is specified by its formal
object which is quote an
entire order of objects from their very
nature
the soi in french accessible to the
human mind's
natural powers objects about which mara
10 makes
two seemingly offhand but important
remarks first these objects are
in the realm of the real so that
philosophy by its own
abstract essence is called to engage
with reality
not merely abstractions second the
reality includes both
created and uncreated being
philosophy actually exists in concrete
historical reality only in conditions
of exercises or states in its real
instantiation
a number of things condition philosophy
particularly the philosophizing human
subjects themselves
and the ways conditions and institutions
in which they philosophize
which maritime calls a regime
in terms of its state philosophy can
legitimately be christian
and develops further towards the
potential of philosophy's essence both
as a habitus in human subjects and in
the corresponding form
of systems of knowledge christianity
does this
in two main fashions by making objective
contributions
that philosophy then appropriates
through its own proper activity and by
producing subjective
reinforcements in the christian
philosopher
these both maritime leader notes
comprise
orders equally needed for philosophy in
an
organic christian regime in normatively
required proportioning to each other
objective contributions take a number of
forms
first there are objects that from their
very nature belong to philosophy's
domain but that philosophers did not
in fact explicitly recognize and that
christian revelation is sent in pure in
plain view
for example creation ex nihilo or god is
being
second there are objects that philosophy
knew well but about which it hesitated a
great deal
which christianity confirms for the
philosopher
an example is a trust in reason's value
third there are supernatural mysteries
philosophy cannot itself on its own
grasp but philosophy
scope and its understanding of the
divine is expanded when it cooperates
with theology in a christian regime
one product of this process maraten
suggests is the metaphysical problem of
the person
fructified by theological meditation on
the trinity
and the incarnation subjective
reinforcement's
efficacy derives from philosophy being
an intellectual habitus
of the human subject enmeshed in a
spiritual matrix with other habituses as
well
as all the other determinate components
and determinations
of human beings thus requiring for its
full development as maritime
says many rectifications and
purifications from the individual
and assists not only of reason but of
the heart
higher virtues for example faith and
intellectual habituses for example
contemplation strengthen and purify the
habitus of philosophy developing and
operating in
and through the person in the human
subject who recognizes the higher
value of superior wisdoms afforded by
christianity and thus orients philosophy
toward
and by them its condition in the subject
is fundamentally changed
in interests of brevity i deliberately
pass over maritime's justification for
treating practical
or moral philosophy differently than
speculative philosophy
except to make three observations first
in maritime's position on christian
philosophy speculative philosophy
furnishes the paradigm
for relations with christianity second
in
christian practical philosophy or moral
philosophy adequately considered
philosophy becomes explicitly
sub-alternated to christian theology in
a way inadmissible
for speculative philosophy third
maritan's distinctions drew criticisms
from two opposed directions
neo-scholastics who held him wrong to
subordinate moral philosophy to theology
and antonin sertian who contended that
what mauritan
argues for moral philosophy ought to be
applied to philosophy
as a whole all right the next section
catholic philosophy maurice blondel
over the course of the debates blondel
refines and expands his own position one
from the start quite complex and
difficult to summarize for several
reasons
one reason that hopefully sets others in
a more intelligible context is that his
position on christian philosophy
develops in essential continuity with
his own systematic philosophy of action
both as an application of that
philosophy and as a restatement of its
fundamental themes and motives
rendering matters more still more
complex is that in 1934
while still engaged in the christian
philosophy debates
blondel began to bring out his awaited
long meditated upon and massive five
volumes
trilogy consisting of the paul say let's
substantially reworking the earlier
philosophy of accion 1893.
one explicit project structuring
blondel's entire philosophical work
was generating a philosophy that would
be both rigorously
philosophical and not only open to
christianity but to terminately
christian
an integral philosophy in an integral
christianity
in his early view a position that he
later softens
no such christian philosophy had been
adequately
developed in the past the ongoing
development of philosophical thought in
modernity while not generating
philosophy adequate to its own
requirements
had critically indicated philosophical
weaknesses and shortcomings of both
pre-modern and modern candidates for
christian philosophy
this had three main implications for
blondel
first reappropriation of past
philosophical systems particularly of
the tomism ascendant in catholic circles
after i tyrdy potress
even if engaging modern thought in
dialogue
would not be sufficient and risk
blocking a better solution
second modern philosophy blondel would
hold the same of most contemporary
analytic and post-modern philosophy as
well
was insufficiently philosophical failing
to consistently apply
its own critical instruments and
standards to itself
and to grapple with three fundamental
and
interconnected problems inevitably
raised for any philosophy
making claims to sufficiency to itself
into reality
the problem of human destiny the
religious problem
and the problem of the supernatural
a critical metaphilosophical approach
towards philosophy itself
and as well as towards other projects of
christian philosophy and their basic
claims and assumptions
is thus necessarily at the heart of the
blown dalian position so here's the next
section
blondel's 1931 engagements
[Music]
his first engagements with other
interlocutors on the subject of
christian philosophy were
mainly critical blondel took on brahir
directly
examining quote his presuppositions his
method of discussion and the character
of his solutions
revealing their deficiencies and
reliance on rationalism's own dogmatism
imposing itself by authority
in this case rationalism becomes
irrational resulting in straight
jacketed philosophy
and stilted history of both christian
thinkers and pre-christian greeks
turning specifically to brahir's
criticisms of himself
blondel points out that they turn out
not to be
individual not only individually untrue
but also mutually
inconsistent if his philosophy of action
by itself bears no intrinsic christian
stamp
or implications then why is that work
construed to be mere apologetics
evidently because his rationalist critic
assumes the believer to inevitably start
from a committed position of faith
which is then smuggled into his
philosophical work
blondel stresses that his method which
precedes by an
indirect and negative way was
deliberately developed and applied to
avoid that charge as he does to
augustine and thomas brahier sets up
blondel
as a straw man his criticisms of jilson
and by extension maritime criticisms in
certain respects off
base set off some but not all of the
basic elements of his position
he first diagnoses two metaphilosophical
assumptions or dispositions that
quote bar the path to the very
possibility of christian philosophy
one which he labels conceptualism
consists in the assumption that
philosophical systems and the activity
of philosophy
must be articulated principally through
and find their finished state and mark
of adequacy
in concepts organized into systems
closed off to
and thus unable to account for and
accept the ongoing tutelage of the
concrete reality
philosophy's task is it is to engage
what cannot be reductively transformed
into concepts is rejected
as non-philosophical by conceptualism
this represents a choice on the part of
philosophers
not in an inevitable requirement and
blondel will advocate for the other
possible option
as an open philosophy or philosophy of
insufficiency
the other stance which he somewhat
idiosyncratically calls historicism
bears directly on the incorporation of
supernatural data into philosophy
thus on the broader problem of the
relations between the natural
and the supernatural orders and
blondel's criticism targets historical
solutions to the problem
of christian philosophy the problem
reduced to its bare bones consists in a
dilemma presenting itself when
any discipline oriented primarily to the
order of natural phenomena
and proceeding by the use of human
natural endowments and their
acquisitions through the ongoing work of
the discipline
attempts to address itself to matters of
the supernatural order without
deliberately adopting the sort of
critical stance provided
by a philosophy of insufficiency on the
one horn of the dilemma
the supernatural data are naturalized or
rationalized
rendering them amenable to incorporation
into philosophical systems or historical
accounts but
at the price of denaturing them in
effect
losing a grip on what is supernatural at
the very same time
is claiming to grasp it on the other
horn the data's supernatural character
is respected
but philosophy of history philosophy or
history becomes vitiated by uncritically
bringing into it
something heterogeneous and
unassimilated
the philosophical alternative to these
two metaphysical assumptions
is philosophical assumptions is
exemplified by but not restricted to the
type of philosophy
blondel attempts to produce by
philosophy of insufficiency he means
that
he means one that in the course of its
exercise and systematic development
thematizes philosophy's own
insufficiency
to fully comprehend rationally
articulate
and systematize its own objects
the ranges of realities to which it
extends
and the human subject engaged in
philosophizing
such a philosophy will also acknowledge
that philosophy's own
intrinsic requirement of autonomy
culminates
in philosophy freely allowing itself to
be further determined guided and shaped
by something transcending philosophy
this is made possible by philosophy
opening in itself and before itself an
empty space prepared not only for its
own ulterior discoveries
and on its own ground but for
illuminations and contributions
whose real origin it is not and cannot
become
this space is not simply a blank
indeterminacy a black hole
or a chimerical fiction projection of
restlessness sickness of the soul
it is precisely because it possesses
contours to discern
a reason for being to meditate on and
render rationally admissible
and attractive and imperious character
that within this space
ongoing meeting of philosophy and
christianity can legitimately occur
without detriment to either
right the next section la problem de la
philosophy catholique this is
blondel's book that has not yet been
translated
in this 1932 work blondel expands his
position on christian philosophy
insisting however on replacing the term
with catholic philosophy
the first part of the book reprints the
letter on apologetics accompanied by his
own annotations glosses and even
retractions in the rest of the book he
develops his position further in several
ways
first he clarifies the relationship
between his critical project and jill
sons
quote is supernatural revelation is
generative of reason it is necessary
first that we be shown how far from
stabilizing everything and closed
concepts
reason discovers in itself needs that
nature does not
satisfy at all something unattained
always naturally unattainable
and nevertheless in coercively hungering
for
attainment he also provides an
admittedly dense formulation
of the desired relationship between
philosophy and christianity the natural
and the supernatural orders quote
neither dependence
nor independence nor simple
juxtaposition of the rational order
and the christian order but a type of
heterogeneity
in calm penetration and of symbiosis
in the very incommensurability he
clarifies his position on concepts
assuring his critics i do not in any way
mistake the legitimate and indispensable
role the realist scope
the transcendent value of concepts
nevertheless
he holds that concepts remain inadequate
and always perfectable or deficient
so that philosophy does not terminate in
them
as in a resting place it is because
philosophy does not finish in concepts
that it can
and must lead towards realities he also
correlates the empty space to a dynamic
and controversial interpretation of
saint thomas
quote the desire of vision of possession
of the divine
of beatitude a desire that every
intellect is belabored by
in its in essence but at the same time
remains inevitably inefficacious without
the gratuitous aid
of the supernatural gift
central to blondel's positive project is
a distinction between states of human
being
united in concrete reality and here's a
set of five
one a state of nature that actually
could subsist but
act also actually has never existed for
humanity in historical and concrete
order
two the state of original justice three
the state of decay
for a transnatural state in which by the
redemption there is revocation
renewed calls solicitations of grace
that do not leave a person in his or her
interior equilibrium but do that do not
yet constitute the life of grace
and lastly five the state in which a
person is introduced
into the supernatural order each of
these states is a potential object and
field of investigation for philosophy so
that for
philosophy even in its most autonomous
spontaneity
there is a possibility or obligation to
correspond in some way to these
differing states three different
broad philosophical projects each one
a part of christian philosophy arranged
in successive states
correspond stages correspond to these
states
first corresponding to the state of
nature essential philosophy
systematically examines necessary
and possible conditions and structures
of human thought and
action at this stage philosophy can
and does become critically aware of its
own insufficiencies including
this desiderium naturally and in ethicox
at the same time
which reason would consider it
unreasonable either to deny
or to claim to satisfy a congenital and
essential disposition the
ineffaceable mark of every finite
intellect even the highest of every
contingent will
even the most powerful at this point
human reason is brought to recognition
opening and orientation
towards the empty space but not yet to
determinately entering it
determinately entering and exploring the
empty space involves a second
philosophical
project a sort of as he calls it mixed
philosophy
philosophy of the possible relations
between essential possibilities
or necessities and realizable
contingents
at this next stage philosophy begins to
address more determinate questions and
to become more concrete
he says yes or no does this place which
opens to the intervention of what alone
can fill and fulfill the creature remain
empty or
rather it is is it in reality occupied
and by what
and if it is occupied by what method to
what degree with what gain
does reasons gaze bear upon the secret
guest
and show one the welcome to give him
the cooperation to contribute to him
this philosophical project
readies philosophy to extend itself
fully to the concrete realities of human
historical existence
to the triune god and the relations
entangling
the human subject and other human
subjects with gods
with god rather at this stage while
entering the empty space
philosophy still maintains a critical
reserve
not so much towards the determinantly
christian supernatural order
as towards philosophy's own adequacy to
the plentitude of reality
now open to and addressing it in the
third philosophical project
philosophy engages what christianity
teaches to be humanities and all other
created beings real condition
at this stage it becomes possible to
quote study the repercussions in
natural man of the different states
trans natural
supernatural or rebel that awaken in
consciousness in the will
data or reactions other than those of a
pure state of nature
two last points about this third
philosophical project are worth noting
first the philosophizing human subject
is implicated within these concrete
states not as an
object of dis and detached study by a
subject whose own condition
does not in any way affect their ability
or even willingness to grasp and
understand them
second this project of real philosophy
involves recuperation
of the type of christian philosophy jill
song and mauritan
articulated what blondel insists on as
its necessary correlate are the
self-critical safeguards that an open
philosophy
a philosophy of insufficiency provides
he cautions without what we have called
this
sanitation the development of christian
philosophy is
compromised or even speaking truthfully
the entire
organism of autonomous philosophy risks
being
dangerously intoxicated and sterilized
next subsection the problem of catholic
philosophy
the 1933 society detude philosophy
session afforded blondel an opportunity
to
further articulate his position and
engage
interlocutors he emphasized he
re-emphasizes that conceptualism and
historicism render a historical solution
to the problem of christian philosophy
as well as contemporary reappropriation
of past christian philosophies
philosophically untenable and
distinguishes three conceptions or
projects of christian philosophy
deficient so long as these
metaphilosophical
assumptions hold sway but recuperable
from the perspective afforded by a
philosophy of insufficiency
first there are the truths that
philosophy and christian doctrine can
both attain
the latter assists insofar as it
confirms them provides them precision
and expands them by purifying them from
doubts
troubles and errors second there are
truths that reason was not able to
discover through its own activity and
powers but that were contributed by
christianity then
offering to speculation a gripping point
enabling extension and growth for
rational thought itself
third christianity modified and
nourished the culture of the west as a
whole
little by little penetrating the entire
intellectual civilization
and its intellect leading to the
critical situation of modernity
which as once again blondel stresses
both makes fully possible and requires
rethinking the problem of christian
philosophy
in modernity by bringing the always
looming crisis between
rational autonomy and christian demands
to a vital point here i'm going to read
footnote 182. a year earlier in his
pseudonymously published article in
philosophy
blondel explains why the historical
condition of modernity imposes
new conditions on and brings new
opportunities for christian philosophy
he writes we can no longer allow such a
question to fall back into the
ambiguities
and approximations with which people
seem to have been hitherto contented
so long as societies and human beings
still lived off of
even secularized acquisitions in an
atmosphere penetrated by christian
contributions
it was possible to avoid a more radical
examination of the very grounds of our
civilization
but prodigious transformations are
carried out in every domain
and call again into question all
speculative or practical principles
and already the revolutionary era we're
traversing a firm's constructive and
organic claims
systematically alien or hostile to all
the intellectual
moral and spiritual traditions of
yesterday's world
from that point on compromise and mere
continuance are no longer
sufficient it's a matter of envisioning
the conflict between
the christian conception of the universe
of society of human destiny
and the new program that is offered just
as much to the intellectual elite as to
popular aspirations
do we understand through this the vital
interest assumed by fundamental study of
the reasons that can and must connect
the highest philosophical speculation
and christianity's very cause
all right back to the section what has
been
only partially carried out and needs to
be carried further
is quote making the very conception of
philosophy evolve
into one in which the problem of the
supernatural is determined
in all of its precision by a rational
critique
that shows its legitimacy and
inevitability
this entails an option similar to that
posed earlier between conceptualism and
an open philosophy this time between
a philosophy that can suffice onto
itself suffice to all of reality and to
its human subjects
and an affirmation of the legitimacy the
reality the indestructible originality
of positive religions thought and life
in the heart of humanity
blondel provides several important
clarifications in addressing his
interlocutors he agrees with devil vay's
criticism critique of superstitiously
hypostatized understandings of reason
fact and revelation
but affirms the intrinsic value and the
original nature of human reason
mareshall suggests that blondel's
christian philosophy and tomism meet in
raising the problem of a natural desire
underlying all human thought and being
for the supernatural
this natural desire is confused is not
immediately apparent and can be
discerned only by an indirect method
it also cannot be achieved by and
through itself and its means
though it can be by grace but it does
open the possibility of the supernatural
order
blondel responds that philosophy in its
activity can reveal
such a quote aspiration and nostalgic
nostalgia congenital and constitutive in
every spiritual creature
this penetrates and motivates the
philosophical activity of the human
subject
and in humanity's concrete and
historical state the positive calling
and the interior exterior stimulations
rendering it obligatory decisive and
accessible are added to this order of
necessary possibility
correlatively however this engagement
and assimilation of the concrete and
historical requires the preliminary and
critical state
of open philosophy in his discussion
with pollyard and berger
blondel adds that the natural desire for
the supernatural in the supernatural's
order
orders approach or calling necessarily
remains marked by ambiguity requiring
quote a work of the soul and of reason
as well as the realization that the
desired transcendence cannot be derived
from the human subject he also amplifies
the theme of the empty space
expanding his terminology so that
infinitesimal
and real fissures riddle human thought
holes
gaps requiring another reality that of
the supernatural
philosophical thought and christian
thought thus reciproc
reciprocally insert themselves into each
other's intercesses
so that no simple dividing line between
philosophy and theology
reason and faith exists but rather
interpenetration
without confusion next section
towards an integral philosophy
in this 1934 piece blondel both responds
to von steinbergen and
further elucidates several aspects of
his own position
he rejects the neo-scholastic suggested
philosophy of christianity as
philosophical reflection on christianity
deliberately carried out from an
intrinsic perspective it would fail to
respect both
the specifically divine character of
christianity
and the completely human character of
philosophy
either this would produce a separated
philosophy or it would fall into the
historicist dilemma
of rationalizing christianity or
bringing a heterogeneous and
unassimilated supernatural into
philosophy
blondel proposes the alternative of
maintaining and
quote essential incommensurability
between the christian order
and the philosophical order while
recognizing that philosophy can prepare
dispositions required so that
access to the invisible soul of the
church remains open to all
so that it keeps ready and free the
place of waiting or possession that only
christianity
deserves and fills he specifies that
philosophy insufficiency must take its
bearings not from
abstract disciplinary distinctions of
philosophy and theology
but from the living thought that
animates philosophy
and sets it within a drama blondel
also argues that von steinbergen
inconsistently calls for philosophy to
extend itself to all the real
but then restricts it to the domain of
concepts of essences of possibilities of
metaphysical necessities
preventing philosophy from engaging
itself in concrete
reality that exceeds this domain in
blondel's view
this relapse into conceptualism stems
from failure to see in the insufficiency
of philosophy
with respect to what lies beyond it a
positive state
the expression of a presence of a power
of a duty
of our thought interiorly be labored by
the a very real
aspiration by a historically set up
vocation
or even by a stimulating and
undeclinable
grace in place of broad theology
blondel proposes a broadened philosophy
a sort of
summa a philosophy extending to all of
the real
including the soul of the church and
humanity's ultimate end
a philosophy structured in three
progressive stages
corresponding to those articulated in
the problem of the philosophy catalyque
the first metaphysical stage opens the
empty space within philosophy
by examining the conditions necessary
for human existence and for human beings
to have a destiny in the second stage
philosophy now conscious of its
insufficiency both to limit itself
and to attain all its objects considers
whether
access to the supernatural and the
response to philosophy's own
insufficiency has not already been
gratuitously and historically provided
whether the empty space is not already
filled
philosophy engages christianity
determinately at this stage
but as a mystery in the third phase
philosophy having in the previous two
grasps what blondel calls the
metaphysical and spiritual armature
that sustains the ascensions of the
christian order
penetrates further into the christian
mystery and determinate concrete lived
christian life this broad philosophy is
what blondel means by
catholic philosophy and responding to
fond steinberg's
advocation not of a christian philosophy
but of a true philosophy
he argues that a true philosophy will be
the open philosophy
he has described
all right so last section of this
last subsection of this section of the
philosophy
of difficult rather in this 1936 article
blondel responds to the question put to
him by the board of the review thomist
what does the attitude the specific
mindset the professional duty of the
philosopher consistent
insofar as his research must be
specified in the presence
of the theologians teachings on truths
where they both must
meet each other while retaining a formal
autonomy
interestingly in this piece he brings
his position closer to jill sones and
mauritan's positions
when discussing ways in which
christianity and christian theology
productively communicate with philosophy
first however he analogizes the
philosopher to a climber ascending an
immense staircase leading up a mountain
whose perspective necessarily differs
from that of the theologian likened to
an aviator who views the itinerary from
above
the philosopher must be continually
attentive to the fiery
the becoming of truth in himself
corresponding to the vertical faces of
the steps so it's better to know it such
as it is
in itself in its essay being which the
theologian
is enabled to see from on high
blondel then distinguishes three
situations of communication between
philosophy and theology
the first involves metaphysical or
moral truths common to the two
disciplines and ideally in an agreement
that works itself out
not at all by abdication superposition
or substitution
but by singularly salutary and pacifying
calm penetration
conformation and precision
the second involves truth's philosophy
did not and was not able to attain to on
its own stemming from revealed mysteries
and philosophy's role on this case is to
quote draw from it some information
some clarity for the mind whose weak
gaze can still take advantage of an
indirect light
while philosophy cannot naturalize these
truths reducing them to philosophical
concepts and must respect their
supernatural origin and status
it can at least meditate upon them
in order to find there a meaning to some
degree illuminated or illuminating
the third deals with the historical and
contingent data the dogmatic facts that
surround the mysteries about which we
have just spoken
that also expressed divine divine
charities
unpredictable and unfathomable in
unfathomable
interventions here blondel counsels
while maintaining a critical reserve the
philosopher must
avoid two erroneous attitudes he must
refrain from transforming what is the
foundational
and constitutive reality of the
supernatural order
into mythic uh mythic
inventions into symbolic projection of
more obscure needs of ascetic or
mystical sentimentality
he also must not ignore or seem to
ignore the totality of
major christian events by treating them
as if they were
only simple contingent details among the
diverse facts of which the world is
composed
since the philosopher's mission is to
quote neglect nothing of concrete and
complete reality both speculative and
practical
remaining faithful to philosophy's own
demands requires
not only observing these points but
thematizing them
within one's philosophical activity
and system so that is the end of the
blondel section
uh then we have gabriel marcel who will
be taking up
next reading we're going to be doing
readings every
thursday during this month from
reason fulfilled by revelation which
will get us to the end of
the introduction and then prepare us for
the
larger work of starting to read the
actual translations from brejiere
blondelle marcel bourne certifiance
desolage
von steinbergen and noel
so i'm looking forward to that if you
have any questions or comments about the
ideas that we've we've talked about
about the
debates in general about the
figures or issues i'm happy to
entertain them we have about 20 minutes
so i can take those now
otherwise i'm happy to end the session
early
and we'll do another one next week
thursday talking about gabriel marcel
and about um
thomas opponents of christian philosophy
right
yeah the neo-scholastic thomas opponents
of christian philosophy
um as a matter of fact by the end of the
month we will get to
uh emil breger's um is there a christian
philosophy which i've translated
for this while i'm i'm waiting to see if
there's any
interesting questions or comments i'll
i'll mention that
i'll tell you a little bit of story so
many of you know that i
was in a faculty fellowship with um
aleister mcintyre back in 2005 at the
university of notre dame
uh over the summer and one of the things
you know we each had to present
something on our current research so i
presented about this and then afterwards
he came up to me and he's like
i don't know if you want to have this
but here's something for you
and he handed me uh a document in a
folder
and it was a meal it was his translation
of emil brahie's um uh
is there a christian philosophy which
was one of the central
documents early on in the debate he had
translated it for a student
and he said you can you know do whatever
you want with this look it over
you know i know you've already got your
own translation but maybe you'd like to
compare it and i was like well
thanks yeah that's that's really cool
and so i did look it over we
were actually pretty close on how he
translated a lot of stuff
so that was always quite nice uh
capricious reason was the revelation i
will leave it at that thanks again love
your efforts at work
reason is one of those things it's it's
a it's an easy word to say
it's a very complicated phenomenon
within us that is determinative
of us and of philosophy and any simple
generalization about reason
you know is is both a product of reason
and likely to also be
wrong about what reason is
uh does this get into any phenomenology
or was it
before it really got going with
heidegger phenomenology did not get
going with heidegger phenomenology got
going with a whole host of people
heidegger was one of them
before heidegger of course there was
husserl and
mock schaeler equally important to
husserl and heidegger
gabriel marcel is a phenomenologist
there were phenomenologists in france
and there's a really great dissertation
by christian dupont
that that shows that what paved the way
for phenomenology to make it
its way into french uh uh philosophy
was henri bergson with his attention to
the immediate data of consciousness
another way of talking about
phenomenology and guess who
maurice blondel from oxio 1893
with his method of imminence so
phenomenology does not play an important
role within the debate as i
i mentioned in previous sessions uh
reading from it there there are some
people discussing phenomenology who
play minor roles within the debate you
could look at edith stein
who was uh the invited guest at the
first
society tom east um
uh session right and
uh she she's got later works discussing
the problem of christian philosophy they
don't know well
the very last entry that i translated
he is using husserlian phenomenology to
argue against there being a christian
philosophy
um dom foiling at the society tomist
the second session which is not
translated in this volume also
uh talked about phenomenology jean-luc
marion is much much much much later
and actually has an article on the
christian philosophy debates where he
gets most of the people he talks about
wrong but that's not entirely surprising
about
mario mario's an interesting guy i've
met him i've actually had
dinner with him at one point um
and he's you know you get a mario you
sort of like to lose right you know what
you're what you're dealing with
or kojev um it's it's uh when he talks
about other people
you're getting mario's take on that and
it's very interesting but it's
it's often not all that close to the
original
um so yeah mario would be much much
later there there are
in fact a lot of um french
phenomenologists
who are closer to the time this is the
1930s
who have a few things to say about it
merlot ponte actually writes about it
in signs but gets gets things about the
debates wrong
but he's aware of the debates i don't
know if levine us
was all that tuned into it um
but yeah that's that's that's a good
good point all right any other
questions comments uh issues people want
to bring up
[Applause]
i'll mention too mario came down to
southern illinois when i was a graduate
student there
and uh we got to
he did a couple presentations he and i
had a couple interactions
outside of the the classroom because i
was sort of at the cusp point of like
um i was like finishing my dissertation
and i was also you know francophone so
he
he liked having somebody who he could
talk to
and then i saw him a couple times up at
the lumen christie events
up in chicago didn't make the
franciscan university steubenville
conference that was devoted to him
because i think i was down in north
carolina at the time maybe
but yeah there's actually quite a lot of
contemporary work
on blondel these days in in french
not so much in english um the
english-speaking world tends to be
when it comes to these figures tends to
be if anybody
knows them dominated by jose and martin
because their stuff got translated a
long time ago you know
uh byring and this might be for later
but do come to a decision is there a
christian philosophy there are christian
philosophies
there is not one single model of
christian philosophy
and that's one of the things that the
debates showed
and is also reflected in the fide
serazio document from john paul ii which
is highly inspired by blondel
as people have pointed out that there
there is an a-christian
philosophy singular there's rather a
whole
set of interconnected ones um
stewart excuse my ignorance would kamu
have been aware interested in these
debates as
an existentialist no not really kamu
kamu didn't have any interest in this
sort of stuff
and camus is you know pretty
straightforward about his his uh
atheism um there's there's just a lot of
things he doesn't take seriously and
and to be fair a lot of the the
catholics that he
you know interacted with were kind of
sanctimonious pricks
so why would he be these guys weren't
but
but um yeah um
there were a lot of of christian
existentialists who were involved in
these and also in the 1940s to 50s
reformed christian
debates that that came later but they're
kind of minor figures
you know um and they're not they're not
ones that got into the big
pantheon of uh you know sartre de bevoir
uh camus and you know the precursors
there's the existentialism was a much
much broader movement than and people
often realize it included people like
leon shastaff who did take part in the
debates
in the very end writing uh the first
essays
in review to metaphysical morale that
would later turn into his book
athens and jerusalem but he he was kind
of late to the game
um and and you know i mean
jill so and martin are often called
existentialist thomas
blondel's philosophy was in
communication with
and and had a lot of same concerns with
existentialism
marcel is of course viewed as an
existentialist he's the first person to
use the term
existence at least in french before long
before
camus or sartre or any of those people
are doing so but he he then abandons the
term after sart kind of
takes over the territory um so
yeah all right well this
this is a a good set of uh questions and
i'm glad you could join me here for the
reading
i think i'll i'll bring it to a close
since i don't see any other
questions we'll do these every thursday
this month probably
continue on as long it's going to be a
while
getting through a book this long but if
we do it like 10 to 15 pages at a time
we will eventually do it maybe by the
end of the year so
i'll see all of you next time and
yeah keep reading keep thinking and
keep studying philosophy